fora tv' the world is thinking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening how are we for signal we're
good
I'm Stuart brands from the long now
foundation maybe wonder what this
Twitter thing is about this data it
turns out is helpful for funders of long
now none of these talks they get to find
out you know what the sort of watershed
of people that feeds into this event is
how many people have been to one of
these before
God how many have not been to one of
these before is it no it's interesting
the drill on these things is this is for
questions on the back put your name on
it and look for somebody in a yellow hat
like mine pass it over to them it comes
up with the front Kevin Kelly combs
through for the stuff that'll really
embarrass the speaker and I will hit him
with it
another thing we may do with this data
is as we move from venue to venue we
find out you know who's well served by
public transit things like that we'd
like eventually to get a bigger police
obviously and the place that we can
count on being all the time so this data
helps us move in the direction of being
able to handle more of an audience with
more regularity and more access for
everybody so thanks for your help on
that I should say tell me about the next
speaker since not everybody knows who
Dimitri Orloff is he's a sketch he's a
close student of how collapse went
forward and the Soviet Union 20 years
ago and notices interesting parallels
going on in the US you always start with
the financial collapse climate change
may figure into it by the time he's
these things play out and one of his
points is that the Soviet Union screwed
up as it is was actually better it
collapsed probably than we are so we can
learn some things from their experience
and move right on through the collapse
into rebirth this is the long term of
thinking we try to encourage in this
organization
saul griffith also is talking about
long-term stuff the weird thing about
climate is that it's like times and its
lead times are so much longer than a
quarterly report or an election cycle or
a news cycle that we're still getting
used to thing in terms of what one has
to do to make something happen
40 years from now and failing to do that
are you willing to live with the
consequences 40 30 20 10 years from now
now Saul is a MacArthur Fellow he got
named last year 2007 last year and n1
and MacArthur fellows it's a lot of
money which is great it's a lot of
attention which is useful because it
gets usually young creative people a
bigger audience and a little more focus
and also they connect with each other
and so the the fellows are in a sense a
lifetime Club of extremely creative
people who infect and infest each other
which then gives them more to infect and
infest us with that's what Saul
Griffiths is here for tonight here he is
Thank You Stuart so I'm super excited
cuz this is the first time I've ever
sold out a house I think so I hope they
indie and I hope desperately to neither
in fact nor infest here tonight
climate change recalculated is the topic
of my talk tonight now I'm not going to
try and tell you that everyone's
equations and all the science is wrong
and you to recalculate it you're going
to get a great result the recalculation
I'm talking about is the type of
recalculation that will help you answer
questions of this kind do you prefer a
glass of wine every evening or do you
prefer to have an annual business trip
would you prefer your taxes spent on
schools or roads
would you prefer a hot shower every day
or would you like to eat meat at every
evening meal so they they will turn out
to be surprisingly relevant questions by
the time we get to the end of the talk
so you've obviously heard about climate
change that's probably why you're here
you have heard about the concept of
carbon footprints and you've certainly
heard about energy independence and
we'll hear more and more but let's look
at these things as though we are sort of
reconciling the short-term us the us
that are sitting here in the audience
with the 10,000 future of us or the
10,000 year of our our children's
children's children's children or
something hopefully doing that and so in
when the talk is called climate change
recalculated it should be maybe
re-envisioned through a very personal
view hopefully we will now answer two
questions how do your personal actions
affect climate and given that can there
actually be a global solution for a
climate change which another way say
you're going to see a big pile of
numbers to show you the climate change
and and energy issues are actually
really an aesthetic issue it's really a
question of what is the quality life and
what is the life that we all sort of
want to live so you're going to see two
stories tonight the the global big
picture how much of all the different
types of energy are there how can you
use them which ones are good
which ones are not so good but to set
the context for that and I used to just
give the talk exclusively about that
very big cold picture of the planet as a
as a physicist would see it and people
would say that's a very cold picture
that a physicist paints and so I put
myself in the picture and so you'll get
that you'll you'll learn more about my
personal life today then you probably
want to know and why it's because
probably about eighteen months ago in
order to sort of understand my context
in this picture I decide to ask this
question much power do I use as an
individual so super basics physics
energy is measured in joules if I was to
lift an apple or this cup of water from
the the ground to the podium that takes
about one Joule of energy if power is
the amount of energy use in a period of
time so if I lift that if you take me
one second that's about one watt of
power to lift that glass to the table if
I lift 40 apples per second from the
ground to the table you can imagine
that's quite a lot of effort that's
about 40 watts and that's about the
amount of power that's driving the
computer that's running this
presentation so these numbers are going
to a lot of you probably know this but
for those who don't I'm just trying to
give you some some intuition for the the
lots of numbers they're going to come
afterwards so here is sort of some order
of magnitude of the power of certain
things so the the bioenergy that's
running you while you're sitting there
in your chair or if you're if you're
standing more likely is about a hundred
watts it takes about a kilowatt or a
thousand watts to boil the water in your
kettle it's about a megawatt is you've
ever seen a very large diesel locomotive
or a very large wind turbine that's
about a megawatt or a million watts it's
very hard to imagine power of larger
sizes than that so maybe you've stood at
the edge of Hoover Dam and you've been
awed by the power of the water that's
about a gigawatt in fact it's two
gigawatts of power and a terawatt which
is 10 to the 12 watts was about how much
power the world used in 1990 hard to
imagine a terawatt it's also about how
much
power you need to launch the space
shuttle but that only lasts for a few
seconds so I'm going to do if you if
you're still struggling for an intuition
about power I'm going to tell you about
my lifestyle and you can imagine my
lifestyle and consequently your own in
terms of the number of light bulbs that
are burning at any instant when you're
talking normally I stand in front of the
slides here I know it wasn't meant to
walk out of the the light and I like to
stand here and say that's not the glow
of genius you see that is that is the
number of light bulbs that it takes to
power my lifestyle so why what so the
convenient why would you use power as a
unit instead of energy because we hear
about an energy problem why what's the
couple of good things about what's
what's allows you to compare activities
you do on different time scales so you
can compare the things that you do
yearly like flying a certain number of
miles to the things you do monthly like
paying your electricity bill to things
you do daily like drink bottled water or
energy drinks you can merely add all
those things together at the once you've
got a what value for all of them add
them all up and that gives you the sort
of power of your lifestyle
it also allows you to consider
non-carbon-based effects of using so
much energy or so much power and we'll
get to that later in the talk so this
was my as you can see I own my own
airline this is the route map that it
will fly you and in 2007 I flew 112
thousand miles if we assume that every
one of those flights was on a fully
loaded 747 operating as well as they can
that's about 18,000 watts of power so
that's 8,000 watts all through the year
is the equivalent of that terms of
driving I drove about 10,000 miles in
2007 that was the equivalent to driving
around the u.s. on this Ralph in reality
it was really just driving to the store
or to work the first four and a half
thousand miles were driving from San
Francisco to New York via Atlanta in the
Honda Insight a hybrid 55 miles per
gallon jumped in a cab from New York to
Boston
rented a car you know one of the big
rental cars from Boston to Key West up
to Jacksonville in in a van a diesel van
the only safe way obviously to go across
the southwest is in the truck and once I
got to Tucson I jumped in my vintage
1959 Volkswagen dune buggy and enjoyed
highway 1 all the way to San Francisco
so ten thousand miles is less the
average American drives 15,000 miles a
year and in reality all of the car the
majority of the cars that I drove in are
much more efficient than the average
American car so I drove less miles in
more efficient cars and it was still
1,500 what the average American that
value could be two and a half or three
thousand watt I live in a small
standalone house in the mission it's two
bedrooms I share it with my wife my half
of the gas bill and the electricity bill
in what is about six hundred and
twenty-five watts you can see here that
I can I can break out the hot shower I
have everyday the gas that we use for
cooking I can even sort of single out
the electric toothbrush and the the
fridge and phone charges using these
sort of wall measuring devices for power
so 625 watts there it turns out at my
office nearly everyone runs four
computers all the time 24 hours a day
using 411 watts of electricity each as
you can see in the winter months January
February December they all leave their
windows open and rut used the gas to
heat it so that was about four I think
about 600 watts if you divided out the
power consumption of my company and
amortized it across everyone
I eat hopefully you all do turns out
that that also consumes a lot of power
personally these are I'm using numbers
here that are taken from reviewed peers
owners in fact throughout the whole talk
if anyone wants the reference list see
me afterwards I tend to believe actually
that no one truly has a handle on the
energy consumption for eating yet but
this would be the conservative estimate
in conservative in one serious way and
then one funny way the funny
conservatism is that this assumes that I
only drink two glasses of wine and
and that that is equivalent to 76 watts
of power there was a there's a funny guy
he's quite a serious guy actually he
runs a blog for wine aficionado it's
called dr. vino he did a study of the
carbon footprint or the energy consumed
to deliver wine anywhere in the world
turns out if you live on this side of a
line roughly between Chicago and New
Orleans it's more energetically
favorable to drink wines from from
Sonoma County and if you live in New
York you should drink French border so
more reasons to live in New York like
you needed them so anyway
maybe I shouldn't say that because I
think the local wines are much better
than they I don't like the French anyway
so obviously I eat more meat or I used
to eat more meat and fish than I should
and that is the majority of the power
consumed in my life and everyone's
probably aware that to create a pound of
meat you have to feed it a lot of green
and so it's a pretty inefficient way to
get your calories surprisingly though
the numbers for farming transportation
and fertilizers so the transportation is
moving that food around the fertilizer
is the embodied you know the energy in
the in the synthetic fertilizers we use
that is really just assuming that those
those are the u.s. wide national numbers
for those three figures and I have just
assumed a one three hundred millions
share very likely I have a probably
better diet a more expensive diet than
most people in the country so this is
almost certainly an underestimate
speaking of taking one three hundred
million shares you also pay taxes your
taxes get spent in all sorts of
different ways so the number of
government departments publish their use
of fuel and electricity and if you if I
took my one three hundred millions share
of the u.s. military's aviation gas and
diesel bill it's about 94 watts to keep
all the silos warm it's about 50 watts
the US government just to run all of its
buildings about 18 once and you're one
three hundred millionth of NASA share of
NASA is one watt of power hopefully
there's some NASA people here I would
happily give them more of my watts
get us out of here and then the US
Postal Service uses a little this does
not take into account all of the energy
that's embodied in the roads in the
actual steel that makes the tankers etc
etc and we'll come to that later
I also own an awful lot of stuff you can
now see everything that I own and so
this comes to the issue of embodied
energy so in every any item you own it
weighs something and that and it's made
out of a material we know how much
energy it takes to make those materials
if you do very conservative assumptions
for all of your objects you can figure
out and you know how long those objects
last you can figure out how much power
they use I own 11 bicycles so that
little bicycle thing it's not one but 11
but because my bicycles last 20 years
and bicycles don't weigh very much it's
not a very big piece of my pie you can
see the cars my Honda or my wife's Honda
Insight that I sort of share and then
vintage Toyota pickup in a very vintage
Volkswagen that's the red section
surprisingly if you look at this and you
think okay if I was to reduce the energy
use of my life where should it come from
you go after the big pieces you find
some interesting things so very big
objects that weigh a lot even if they
last a long time use a lot of energy so
your house the your cars your boats the
other unusual things for me are things
that you get very regularly like the
newspaper or detergent or washing powder
or toothpaste because you just get them
regularly that that's quite a large
portion of your power and then the green
section at the bottom is my furniture I
think yellow is toothpaste detergent
washing powder the purple section you
should be thankful for because that
means I'm not standing before you naked
that's all my belts and shoes and
clothes and the purple section I can't
remember I'm sorry the difference
between this slide and this slide is the
curd vada roar the designer whose
hopefully sitting in the audience did
this slide and I did this slide
kirk is amazing if you ever have an
opportunity to work with coupon roi you
should so this is actually my entire
life so 17,000 watts you'll notice later
in the talk that actually my my new
estimate is 18,000 watts it's because
you keep forgetting that you do things
that use power that big blue green area
in the top right hand corner is your tax
dollars at work
and part of that goes to in all of the
energy that you saw previously for the
diesel etc but a lot of it is in unusual
things like for example if you do
conservative assumptions of how much
energy is embodied in all of the road
infrastructure in the United States and
you divide it by everyone and you assume
that all those roads last 40 years the
embodied energy in the road
infrastructure is about 330 watts or 2
or 3% of the average Americans power
consumption obviously the biggest well
everything on the left hand side is
basically my flying you can see my
driving there so I won't be this to
death but you can you can it is in fact
possible to understand how all your
energy is used so that was just me this
is me and my lady friend you probably
went to a high school with about a
thousand people the same way I did you
can imagine a thousand people you live
in a city order of magnitude a million
people you can sort of imagine a million
people you have no chance of imagining a
billion people and that's a really long
and awkward segue into the demographics
of energy use so you would say solve you
used 18 thousand watts is that a lot or
a little so you can actually use gross
national data to get a per capita power
consumption by country for every country
in the world the United States typically
likes to think it's number one at
anything at everything
unfortunately it's number ten behind
Canada which are Americans who live
somewhere colder
I think I've managed to offend 90% the
audience in one sentence I'm quite proud
of that and then you'd see that there
are some unusual things you know in
Kuwait and Bahrain and Qatar they
basically burn oil to do air
conditioning all the time so those
people are pretty high Australia that's
my accent that's in 15th place so you
can sort of get a sense of the numbers
of different countries and then the
green line that I've put in there is the
global average 2200 watts is the per
capita global average we might come back
to this slide later but so the 18,000
watts I use really shocked me I thought
I'm a bicycle commuting guy who runs a
renewable energy company in hippie San
Francisco I must be better than the
average American turns out I use about
twice as much power as the average
American so it's a little surprising and
doing this process is incredibly
illuminating for you you can look at the
historical increase in power consumption
by country this is one of my graphics
not cooks and I've tried to put the the
maps in I lost this is interesting
I sort of yeah like you know I couldn't
I couldn't get all the little tiny ones
but so America has is increasing but not
that rapidly compared to things like
China and Russia which you can see up
there and India one of the most
interesting things about this graphic is
the big discontinuity and around I mean
you know just before 1990 and that is
the Soviet Union changing into lots of
smaller countries so this is maybe only
interesting politically how did the
world make all of its energy and use it
grossly in 2007 these are International
Energy Agency numbers the majority of it
was in producing electricity you can
break down how we've made that
electricity by fuel type and you can see
the the scale their transportation was
nearly all oil that was in second place
you can sort of change these buckets
around to mean different things but it
sort of gives you a pretty good gross
sense of how we use energy globally so
what's the result of using all of that
energy it has led to this problem this
graph has been made
people who can fill every audience that
they speak to and it's going up so this
is the co2 concentration as measured in
mountain or lower amount top and away
and you can see the you can see the
seasonal variation and you can see that
we're now it's this leaders I think that
the last data point I have is 2003 I
think we're now up to about 387 parts
per million so you'd say well who put
all that carbon into the atmosphere
I find this a particularly interesting
aspect of the demographics so you can
you can sum the cumulative CEO to
emissions from fossil fuel burning for
every country in the world for all those
that have kept statistics and it tells
you this of all of the carbon that's in
the atmosphere 90 Giga metric tons or
billion metric tons of it was the United
States so happily there at number one
position again in number two it's Russia
number three is China number four is
Germany you have to do some pretty weird
political remapping of the data because
Germany changed hands so many times in
the 200-year data set etc etc but
basically the first six or seven
countries there have produced 90 to 95%
of the carbon in the in the atmosphere
so in terms of who is responsible for
solving this problem the evidence is
fairly damning and I don't think it
leaves you any choice but to figure out
who should act first and fastest so
let's think about all that carbon this
is it this is a very very cartoony look
at where all the carbon in the world is
there is around about 700 gigatonnes of
carbon in the atmosphere we put another
eight gigatonnes of carbon this is not
carbon dioxide but carbon if you want
carbon dioxide numbers just multiply
everything by 4.4 we put eight billion
tons of carbon in the atmosphere every
year the oceans reabsorb about two
billion tons of that we know how much
carbon is in all the soils in the world
it's about 3,000 billion tons there's
40,000 billion tons
40,000 billion tons of carbon remaining
the oceans both of those numbers are
reassuring because there's so much there
there's a chance that we can take some
of the carbon the atmosphere and
actually drive it back there the
scariest number on this graph is that
the amount of carbon left in vegetation
that hasn't been burnt yet is equal to
the amount the atmosphere so we
shouldn't burn too much of that and the
fact that there's still 1,600 Giga tons
of carbon in the ground of the carbon
that we burn is the atmosphere around
about 55% seems to stay and linger there
and that's why you don't sort of get 8
minus 2 is 6 going into the atmosphere
you sort of end up sort of ratcheting
that by a couple of billion tonnes per
year right now that those carbon flows
have resulted in this problem these this
is the best graphic I have seen two very
very visually represent the temperature
rises globally over the past 25 years so
for every large red dot this is actually
from the the Stone report in England
every large red dot represents a 1
degree Celsius temperature raised per
decade for the last 25 years so that's
maybe six or seven degrees Fahrenheit in
the last quarter of a century for every
large red dot you see there so be a
little be a little front alright so
here's my fantastic great question that
I think you we all really need to answer
for ourselves really quickly what
temperature are we going to choose as
the target for Humanity this is this
gets to the question of aesthetics what
type of life do we want to live on this
planet that we have so this is a really
terrible slide to try and give you a way
that you might figure that you might
think about how to answer the question
of what temperature so there are climate
models into those those climate models
are based on physics etc we can actually
they're they're actually doing a very
good job of predicting the sort of
matching historical data and predicting
future data with those models we can
then come up with scenarios you've heard
of scenarios scenarios aware
and scientists sit down and say if the
world does this how much carbon will
that produce you feed that back into the
climate model and it tells you what the
atmosphere might stabilize at and after
people have done scenario models then
there are impact studies the impact
studies the climate science that gets
all the headlines they're the things
that say at 1 and 1/2 degrees Celsius as
you can see on the left axis here is
temperature we will lose 10% of all
species at two and a half degrees
Celsius we will lose 15 to 40 percent of
all species at 3 degrees above where we
are in 1990 is the base level at 3
degrees above you'll get 1 to 4 billion
people facing water shortages you know
three and a half it just gets worse and
worse and worse there all the nightmare
scenarios so basically you would
probably like to say how far down you
know how far up that list of nightmares
do I wish to go before I've said enough
and a lot of the consensus has been
around about 2 degrees should be enough
that'll mean a hundred million refugees
crossing borders I think the State
Department mobilizes troops if they if
they hear of about fifty or a hundred
thousand people crossing a border as
refugees so a hundred million means a
lot of littlespot wars around the world
anyway so 2 degrees you know the other
problem two degrees is it might reverse
the thermohaline cycle which will
disrupt the oceans cooling mechanisms
and throw European or an ice age and
everywhere else into hell
and so okay let's okay we'll stop
painting the whole picture
let's save two degrees is where you want
to get so there's the consensus is if we
hit a target of 450 parts per million
you've got about a 30% chance of staying
below 2 degrees so you could argue that
let's shoot for 2 degrees because 450
sounds achievable unless cross our
fingers and hope that if we hit 450 it
really is only 2 degrees but to give you
an idea of how long I've been giving
this talk which is about a year
the really encouraging thing to me is a
year ago it was scandalous to say 450
parts per million because everybody like
that's impossible that's too low the
consensus was 550
but fortunately Jim Hanson has been out
Jim Hansen from NASA being America's
leading climate scientist
and he has managed to get into the
public dialogue with at 350 parts per
million is the correct answer he has a
much better way of arguing for 350 than
I did in the last slide arguing for 450
he says humanity evolved in a world that
had always less than 350 if you want to
have any world that looks like what we
evolved in let's stay below that I think
that's probably a pretty pretty wise
words let's go back to 450 and assume
that's what we're going for
and we're going to accept two degree
temperature rise what do you have to do
one way of thinking about it is you've
kind of got to balance this equation
you've got to have about the same amount
of carbon going into the atmosphere
every year as is being sucked down into
the oceans this is still not a rosy
picture because if you're putting that
carbon in the oceans you're increasing
ocean acidity and that has bad effects
on fisheries and coral and all the rest
but still cross your fingers this is a
better picture than just going off the
charts that's not an entirely replica
again this is a Kirk slide this is a
Seoul slide the that's not in what I've
just presented to you is not entirely an
accurate picture because really with
carbon dioxide going in the atmosphere
it's more about it's about how much
carbon darker burn we can burn anymore
right and so this is sort of this is
actually a guy called Jeff Kumi did this
work in the 80s this is twenty years old
this was a very simple model that is
largely still valid for understanding
what effects putting a billion tons of
carbon into the atmosphere has on the
parts per million concentration of co2
so if you put a billion tonnes of carbon
in the atmosphere
you get about 0.26 increase in the
atmospheric concentration or if you make
one terra watt of power for one year
using coal it increases the past four
million by 0.2 for oil you can see at
point one five and gas is better at
fossil fuel again about 0.1 one so we're
at about 380 390 we've got about sixty
parts per million to go to get to 450
that means you've got about 400 terawatt
years of fossil fuel burning 400
terawatt years as a measure of energy
it's just sounds like power what does
that really mean that means you've got
about 40 years of 10 terawatts of fossil
fuel burning or about 20 years at 20
terawatts to stop at 450 all right
so now I'd sort of tried to ask a
question okay if we've got to state you
know if we've got to get the carbon
going into the atmosphere down to one or
two gigatonnes how much power could
humanity get turns out you know we've
chosen two degrees we're shooting for
450 we understand where the equilibrium
point will be you'll only get two to
three terawatts of Tower from carbon
fuels to drive humanity if you want to
stabilize at 450 if you want to
stabilize at 350 it looks like zero so
turns out that doesn't make a lot of us
we'll get there anyway so hopefully
you're now asking yourself well how much
power does humanity use turns out we use
quite a lot
some people say we use eighteen
terawatts that's because they count all
of the plant matter in the world and
it's various uses agriculturally and and
in burning for a cooking etc if you ask
the International Energy Agency they'll
say it's 15 or 16 terawatts because they
pretty much count the more traditional
fossil fuel sources I guess more
recently traditional to be correct all
right how do we use it this is how the
world uses its power in terawatts all
right so that's obviously not gonna last
a thousand ten thousand years so I've
told you we can only really burn two to
three terawatts worth of fuel if we want
to stabilize at 450 and have that sort
of aesthetic of world and this is
telling us we want 16 terawatts to power
humanity so that's not gonna last
what of it what are the other options so
how can we produce this 16 terawatts of
power few humanity without putting too
much carbon into the atmosphere this is
the only slide that you need to remember
in my talk this tells you this is
basically the playbook for Humanity so
in the top there we have 85,000 terra
watts of Sun coming in so that's the
amount of power in solar energy that's
hitting the surface of the earth at any
instant you've probably heard of
numbers of 170,000 terawatts that's what
hits the outer atmosphere that's the
principle input we also get a little bit
input from space in the in the form of
tidal energy from the moon so as the
moon goes around the earth and makes the
the oceans lift up and lift down that's
tidal energy the scary thing about that
is if you if we built a hundred percent
efficient tidal machine it would and
we've flattened all of the tides so they
no longer went up and down you'd only be
powering one-fifth of humanity today so
it's not going to scale similarly with
coastal waves if you put a hundred
percent efficient way of Collector
around every coastline in the world
you're only going to get about one
one-fifth or one-sixth of humanity's
power supply so when someone submits you
a business plan for wave parents's wave
power will save the world you say wave
power might save some cities in northern
California and the Bay of Fundy but it
doesn't scale the humanity one of the
sources of power that does scale the
humanity is wind power that's the second
largest after solar there's 3,600 terra
watts of wind that's why i work on wind
specifically high-altitude wind we need
to we need to figure out how to get at
that turns out you know we know that the
the Hoover Dam is awfully powerful you
might ask how many Hoover dams are out
there well if you collected every
raindrop as it hit every continent on
the world and you ran all of those
droplets of water through the Hoover Dam
you'd only get 25 terawatts if you
waited for all of that water to get in
the river you only get seven terawatts
surprisingly you know we hear a lot
about biofuels what happens if we took
all of the photosynthetic activity on
the planet that means every mangrove
every grassland every tree and we burn
them every year and let them regrow you
only get about 90 terawatts of that 90
only sixty five is on land so it's a
fully powered humanity with biofuels
you'd have to take one quarter of all
the photosynthetic activity on the
planet there's some heat in the ocean
you could extract ocean thermal gradient
it's not you don't really want to screw
with that as we're already screwing with
the ocean currents
there's also geothermal so geothermal is
a hard one to express the renewable flux
geothermal is about 32 terawatts that's
the natural rate that it comes out of
the earth you could extract that faster
but you would be cooling cooling the
rocks faster than they replenish so that
gives you the picture all right so what
is the challenge humanity uses 16
terawatts 3 you know we can only get 2
let's be generous 3 terawatts of that
from fossil fuels we've got about one
terawatt of nuclear today and about half
a terawatt of hydro so you get one and a
half there so the new clean energy we
need to make in the next 25 years is
around 16 minus 3 plus 1.5 so we've been
neat about eleven and a half terawatts
let's take a wild guess at how you might
do that and in order not to offend
anyone in the audience I'll just make it
fairly equal we'll do two terawatts of
that with photovoltaics 2 with solar
thermal 2 with wind 2 with geothermal 3
with nuclear and we'll give half a
terawatt to biofuels so that would
actually be your 11 and a half that
sounds easy that sounds doable there's
probably a lot of Engineers and the bill
in the in the room you just want to say
well how fast do I have to build it and
what do I have to build it's pretty easy
to do to terawatts of photovoltaics in
25 years and let's assume they're really
good ones 15 percent efficiency that's
about 100 square meters a second every
second for 25 years so that's probably
every 5 seconds you've got to cover this
auditorium with solar cells that gives
you 2 terawatts out of your 11 1/2 for
solar thermal you can get 30% efficiency
if they're well sited that's where you
take a mirror and you you heat up a pool
of water or preferably a molten salt and
then you use that heat to drive
generators steamed or otherwise you'd
need to make 50 you need to install 50
square meters of mirrors every second
for the next 25 years terms of wind
turbines you'd need to build 12 3
megawatt wind turbines every hour so a 3
megawatt wind turbine is the largest
wind turbine you've ever seen it's about
the size of this whole building in
diameter by 100
meters in diameter so basically or the
other way to express that is roughly one
every five or six minutes terms to get
your three terawatts of nuclear power
this is to be ambivalent about the
political aspects of that you need to do
one three gigawatt nuclear plant every
week for the next 25 years I think the
US has eight or ten slated for approval
in the next decade so we're just a
little behind schedule but I am sure
we'll pick it up with the Obama
administration
all right geothermal to terawatts a
geothermal that's basically 300 megawatt
steam turbines every day for the next 25
years so 100 megawatts steam turbines
probably the size of this room but it's
more like stainless steel and this is
not counting the holes that you have to
drill to do that all right and just for
kicks let's get our last 1/2 terawatt of
biofuels so we can fly jets it's an
Olympic swimming pool of genetically
engineered algae that's four times more
efficient than the best genetically
engineered biofuel we have today so
we're being a little ambitious
technologically but assume we get that
and you need to fill one of those in
Olympic swimming pools every second for
next 25 years
then someone will say but cements really
bad because cement we know that cement
produces a lot of carbon let's not use
that so let's not make swing pools why
don't we just fill in a natural land
formation turns out this would be
Wyoming I think so I don't yeah I didn't
mean to pick on any of the Wyoming
people like it just as easily said New
Zealand yeah
all right so then you'd say okay that's
pretty scary they sound like really big
numbers is that at all possible
industrially or another way to phrase
that is what should Detroit actually do
all right well this is not really the
Detroit question this is don't tell
coca-cola but this is the killer
business plan for the 21st century so
the Americans drink 110 billion cans of
soda every year aluminum cans if you cut
all of those aluminum cans in half and
you flatten them out and you polish them
nicely as aluminum can you made them
into mirrors that represents 200
gigawatts of solar thermal capacity
every year so coca-cola is going to
return to his original business plan of
selling you really concentrated packets
of sugar then they don't have to ship
the aluminum around and they're just
going to take the reserved aluminum
capacity and in ten years
Coke and Pepsi will make two terawatts
of solar thermal that's awesome problem
solved
Nokia again I think when I first made
this slide Nokia in fact only made nine
phones every second I think they got to
12
I suspect next year will be not 12
Nokia Intel AMD Apple if you took all of
them in their industrial plant they can
probably do that's roughly the scale to
do the sort of the photovoltaics
required GM yeah slides are really out
of date Jim used to make one car every
two minutes they used to make one
transmission every one minute General
Motors and Ford together you could argue
it may be able to make one wind turbine
every five minutes so it's it's not it's
not impossible I think this is a good
example when we were retooling for World
War two in the United States they made
three hundred thousand aircraft I think
they were making one that one or two
thousand a year up until 1939 in between
1939 and 1945 they made three hundred
thousand aircraft so aircraft it's
roughly the size of a wind turbine three
hundred thousand wind turbines that
would be close to half of the American
electricity grid okay so not impossible
at all but it's you know people say this
is a Manhattan Project this is an Apollo
project
sorry they're science projects Fusion is
a manhattan project or an apollo project
right and we
one fusion to come true but the rest of
this is more like retooling for world
war two except the Germans the French
the British the Americans are all
playing and the Japanese are all playing
on the same team it's totally doable but
we have to think a little more like that
so this is okay I've got you all
depressed this is a super optimistic
slide right so what does this tell you
in 1965 the planet was using was able to
generate five terawatts of power in 2005
we were able to generate generate 15
terrawatts so in 40 years we installed
10 terawatts of generating capacity
right 10 that's not much different to
11.5 there is precedent it is
industrially possible so there's a
there's a note for for feeling
optimistic okay awesome we can do this
but if you're thinking in the long now
sense of the word you might want to
think ahead because what we're about to
do is in fact and indeed pretty awesome
so what might what other things you
might you consider and this returns to
the question of why would you measure
things in watts instead of carbon
because if you use what's you can do
things like figure out you can translate
into land area so how much of the planet
are we going to use to build this engine
to run us so for those particularly
observant people in the audience you've
just noticed that I say that the
incoming solar flux to the earth is
twelve seventy that is wrong I'll tell
you in advance it's thirteen hundred and
sixty-six it doesn't really matter
anyway there's that's about how much
power comes in at the upper atmosphere
we lose some in the atmosphere due to
reflection obviously you lose fifty
percent of it during day and night you
lose some with clouds and with weather
you lose some with geography and
latitude and globally the average power
density of the solar flux is ninety to
three hundred watts per square meter and
we have a photovoltaics and we have
solar thermal and those can have
technology efficiencies between 10 and
40 percent it's unlikely that we're
going to get ever get any of those about
50 percent so this is pretty good range
and if you take all of that and then you
also compensate for the fact that you
don't when you lay solar cells down you
don't cover every square inch you cover
maybe fifteen percent of the land and
with solar thermal you really only
covered
twenty-five percent because you track so
the actual solar energy influx to
electrons gives you about ten to twenty
watts per square meter of land we may do
twice as well but we won't do ten times
as well so keep that in your head 10 to
20 watts per square meter for wind
turbines 100 meter wing diameter wind
turbine is it's three megawatts there's
a capacity factor because the wind
doesn't blow all the time that's
typically 33% so a three megawatt wind
turbine really gives you about a
megawatt averaged out over a year we
space those wind turbines 10 diameters
apart and 10 deep typically sometimes
they can be three by eight so if you
take that megawatt that we get and the
kilometer squared that we have you get
about one watt per square meter maybe
two watts per square meter of land use
hydroelectricity I didn't really know
how to do this number so I cheated and I
just said what's the area of Lake Mead
the feeder to the Hoover Dam
it's 639 square kilometres Hoover dams a
couple of minutes a couple of gigawatts
you get about three watts per square
meter for hydroelectricity that's a map
of the Hoover Dam it's not an internal
organ just incidentally biofuels so if
you filled Lake Mead with three percent
efficient bioengineered algae and I mean
filled it so you could basically walk on
this algal mat it will still give you
about 2 or 3 watts per square meter so
here is Seoul's map of the world the
world the old land masses of the world
are now square what you can see here
this is actually every country in the
world represented as area so that the
largest land area is in fact Russia and
you know so that's it China is in second
actually I have to now recount that
because an angry Canadian
insulted by my first comment at the last
time ago this talk said Canada is the
second-largest country in the world
turns out that's true but only just
then you know you can see this top six
countries Russia China Canada USA Brazil
Australia they're pretty big in terms of
land area so I I would like to invent a
new country called renewest an renewest
an is 10 terawatts renewable power to
terra watts of wind fiber solar one of
hydro two of biofuels and
it's about this big so renewest and it
turns out is the seventh largest country
in the world so what does this say to
you it says where engineering machines
that are country sized as we endeavor
into this clean energy future and you
want to probably be very careful you
want to use the most efficient
technologies by land area because if you
use two percent efficient solar cells
instead of 15 percent efficient solar
cells it'd be that stripe becomes bigger
than Russia for example so choose
carefully there's another way of
expressing that so this orange hit area
here this is the land area per person in
the USA this lighter orange is land area
per person globally as square 140 meters
by 140 meters for my personal power
consumption if I had those 15 percent
solar cells
I need a 41 by 41 metre solar cell to
run my personal life that is a lot
larger than the roof on my house so
please install solar cells in the roof
of your house it's a great idea but just
don't stop right put them on your
neighbor's house put them all over the
place
paint the streets with them the average
u.s. citizen is this green one and this
is this sort of 15 ish meter on a side
square that is the land area required
for the average global citizen all right
so you got to choose carefully you got
to act quickly it is possible and you
have to be a little wise and you have to
think a couple of steps ahead or you can
make mistakes in this challenge all
right so let's come back to putting
ourselves into the picture so you now
realize that the 18,000 watts for 17
thousand watts and Saul Griffiths life
looks a little extravagant because if
everyone in the world went from 2,500
watts to 18,000 watts suddenly we're not
going to need to have just renewest and
we're going to need that six or seven
renewest ants right that's not going to
scale so it's inevitable the China and
India bring their power consumption per
capita office and probably we shouldn't
begrudge anyone in in the less developed
nations to do so and that sort of means
that we have to go down this is what a
lot of people talk about when they talk
about efficiency
my personal pet favorite hate is people
who stand up and say efficiency is the
biggest energy source we know efficiency
is not an energy source efficiency is
using less energy it's a lot more like
abstinence than being an energy source
all right so there's my old life so we
remember my old life it's you even know
how many how many what's it takes my
underwear this is my new life so I'm
going to shoot to be roughly at the
global average 2291 watts how would my
life change to do that all right so this
is my new brood map my airline has got a
strictly changed thing I now get to fly
once per year to the East Coast return
once every three years I get to fly to
Australia to visit my parents once every
five years I get to go looks like I'm
flying to France but I think I want to
go a little further go to Italy once
every 10 years I get to go to Hawaii to
go surfing that will still be 980 3
watts grossly half of my power
consumption this is assuming again that
the I'm flying fully loaded seven four
sevens I now get to drive quite a lot
less six times a year I get to drive two
Sebastopol in a 55 mile per gallon
Honda twice a twice a month I get to
drive the same 55 mile per gallon car to
Alameda where I work both times I'm
going to be carpooling once a month I'm
carpooling in a in a van with four
people two to go visit looks like Google
and then twice a year I get to take my
dune buggy out to go surfing now
obviously you know that I'm lying as
those of you know me you will know that
I'll go to Sebastopol twice a year to
see my in-laws and go surfing six times
so this is obviously a lot less driving
than circumnavigating the country I'm
now call myself six sevens vegetarian I
can't kick the habit completely so I try
to eat very good meat once a week
instead of bad meat all the time
obviously I'm lying when I tell you I'm
going to only drink one glass of wine a
night so this might be the really hard
thing to do and the only value in my new
lifestyle I went up is vegetable use in
terms of stuff I just have to own less
stuff and make it last 10 times as long
or sometimes I call this the the Rolex
and Mont Blanc pen approach to life so
that just sound that just made me sound
like a pretentious wanker I'm I'm really
not I'm a deep green environmentalist
and what you want is when your child is
born or when you were born to be issued
with a Rolex and a Mont Blanc pen and
that's the only writing implement the
only timepiece you get for your whole
life right so we solved just now for
writing and time reading but how about
cell phones so I think this is actually
kind of a great challenge right how do
you make the first company that makes a
cell phone that will last a lifetime
totally wins in my heart that would be
the most amazing for everyone the
audience who have just got laid off
please go and start a company to make a
cell phone that last 100 years that
would be the best thing you can do all
right
I'm not sure why that slides there how
that was a point about oh okay now this
is every business model you need for the
next century pick any piece of that pie
do it with one-tenth the amount of power
or make something that's ten that will
last ten times longer and you've just
done your bit to save the world you this
is when people talk about the green
economy you know a quarter of the energy
we use is just in our crap just go after
this just take any one of those things
and make it a better product and you're
saving us ironically we used to have
drinks in the fridge and my energy
company called energy drinks they have
they have a nutrition label that we're
used to seeing and ironically we have a
- you know a 2,000 calorie per day diet
is what we aim for if you weigh the
plastic of the container of that
material just assume that the water in
it and the
that sugar comes for free but just the
plastic in the in the bottle and the
lead and the cellulose in the label if
you weigh those up when you figure out
the embodied energy to make that and how
much it would take to refrigerator to
transport to Europe if you had a 2000
watt lifestyle drinking one of these per
day would be four and a half percent of
your daily value I think you would look
at every product you ever consumed
extremely differently if we had this
labeling on all products I'm sure you
would choose a glass of wine each day
rather than this alright alright so it's
all possible and we have to think pretty
radically different and it's pretty
obvious that we have to change our
lifestyles but we forgot a couple other
things which is possibly the hardest
part of this entire project is going to
be to turn off the current carbon
dioxide emitters so historically when we
use less energy when we figure out more
efficient ways to do things we just use
more of it so as we bring new power
plants online that are renewable the
temptation is to leave the old ones
running you just can't do that and the
other very difficult thing to do is to
stop deforestation
it's a deforestation you know produces
10 to 20 percent of the co2 in the
atmosphere so you obviously you have to
bring a halt to that or the entire
project just laid out is sort of lost oh
he's a super super encouraging slide
this is one of the more optimistic ones
so this is a graph of the energy
consumption in the u.s. over the last
century and it turns out that we have a
fantastic technology for lowering power
consumption
and you can see the first experiment in
that was the depression worked a treat
great during the oil crisis awesome
during the recession and then for the
six months after September 11 when we
didn't fly very much we also did pretty
well so I'm really really excited to see
2008 and 2009 energy consumption data
because I'm a numbers nerd and to see
how it fits on this map so you can you
can make you can make light of this
situation the good side of a down
economy is that we are losing using less
energy the bad side is is we are tempted
to invest less into renewable energies
and the solutions that we need obviously
we should think carefully about our
priorities and then obviously we also
need to think about what happens when we
come out of this economy right you don't
to go straight back to the old work we
should use this as the nucleating
instance to figure out how to keep the
trend going down if we had the sort of
the the downward slope of the of the 80s
recession or the 30s depression starting
today that would be roughly the type and
we just sustain that slope that would
get us to our target but we need to
figure out how to do that while
improving quality of life and it's to
the aesthetic question and the Mont
Blanc and Rolex question so if you were
living in as 2255 what world you have to
think pretty differently the temptation
is I'll go and buy my hundred mile per
gallon equivalent Tesla and it's all
solved it turns out if you had under
mile per gallon car you get to drive
that for about 20 miles today and that
would be five hundred of your twenty two
hundred fifty watts twenty miles per day
is less than you are driving today so
the average u.s. person it's about forty
miles per day so if you were driving
half in a hundred mile per gallon car
it's still a quarter of your issues so
you know it makes you think twice about
that and is 100 miles per gallon really
ambitious enough this is the Citroen
deux chevaux the French president went
to Bollinger who was the designer for a
Citroen and said in 1932 can you design
me a car that will carry four peasants
to market plus their eggs it has to
drive over an unplowed field has to do
60 kilometres an hour and it should get
he expressed it three litres per 100
kilometers so blunt you all went away
and and 1938 returned with its the dish
of oh and indeed the dish of Oh had
originally shipped with an eight and a
half horsepower motor and could get 70
75 miles per gallon so he's 100 miles
per gallon target 70 years after that
really ambitious enough know why was
this car efficient it was slow and it
was really really lightweight the seats
were hammocks it had a cloth roof and it
was dangerous so to that point one of
the best things we could do instantly to
make a really big dent is to reduce the
speed limit and what would you reduce it
to 55 was one shot probably you want to
go a lot further than 55 and it might
sound shocking to reduce the speed limit
just as a point of note the average
speed traveled in any city in the world
of more than a million people in a
commute is around hovers between 9 and
12 miles per hour I suspect if you
slowed traffic down you would increase
the speed of commuting just cuz it'd be
lesser screw-ups so I had an intern this
summer I made him drive in circles on an
F on a runway and he had to do 100 miles
and every every speed you saw here
turns out the funnier aspect of this
story is it was there was three days but
he'd been there all summer and just
wrote boring code all summer and he was
like a code writing robot and three days
for the in the summer I wanted this day
to find no intimate said I'd really like
you to do something it's a little
ridiculous this is well I've been really
hoping that I got to do something
ridiculous you don't wanna go back to
school without a stupid story I said I
want you to drive in circles for three
days he says awesome and and he says I
learnt to drive stick last night which
this makes my wife is in the audience
nervous because it's her car and it's
stick and anyway so with as he bunny
hopped out of the driveway yeah so we
had to remove the first few data points
anyway so the optimum
optimum speed to drive a this particular
car is about 30 miles per hour and you
get 85 90 mile 918 five ish miles per
gallon so I think lowering speed limit
that's a point there or do this even
better do this I think electric motor
scooters that's the other thing if
you're not making cell phones that last
last 100 years please make electric
motor scooters all right so you might
ask me okay so for a year now you've
known all this data and you're trying to
reduce the power consumption in your
life how did you do well I did about 17
or 18 thousand watts of power in 2007 I
think this year I will use about 12,000
and my life has only improved so far so
I'm eating less and definitely more
healthfully I'm exercising more doing
more commuting by bicycle I'm spending
more time with my family by sort of
traveling less finding that living
closer together with your friends and
and and what people certainly helps I'm
doing a lot less business travel which
is great business travel actually sucks
higher quality better designed products
it's a really nice filter on your
purchasing consumer self to just say I
will only buy good things because you
can't afford many and so that's totally
working for me
let's junk in my house the house is
cleaner cuz there's a less crowd and you
know hopefully if we're all doing this
we're breathing clean around drinking
cleaner water so I think there is a
reasonable argument to say that we can
have much higher quality lives while we
sort of hit the goals we want here the
one thing I didn't mention here is I
could have really reduced my power
consumption for a 2008 buy another three
or four thousand watts if I stopped
paying taxes now who knows how well we
hear the US government apportions the
tax dollars but I suspect if I were
running the show I wouldn't spend the
power on behalf of the citizens it is
now and it's a fairly serious point that
we actually should be lobbying
government to use the power that it uses
on our behalf a lot better than it
actually does and roughly imagine what
portion of your salary that you pay in
taxes that's grossly the portion of the
energy that the government decides on
your behalf so finish with the
obligatory photo of the world oh okay no
that's for later all right so that's it
and I guess there's going to be hard
questions thank you
oh actually I've called you up here too
soon oh you can stay around so
everyone's probably wondering why on
earth it did so bring his IV drip
so this is illustrate a point a lot of
the math that we put into making this
presentation there's a fantastic guy
called Raffy Horan and his crew at
synthesis studios in Boston they've
turned that into a website called Watson
Watson comm and you can go through and
enter in your data it's like a carbon
calculator on steroids except it uses
energy and once you've figured out how
much you power you use and I'm up to
18,000 watts you can say for example
visualize for me you can do me versus
light bulbs or how big is my personal
wind turbine how big is my solar panel
but I happen to like the one you versus
oil and if you look at my life if oil in
pints per day I'm in about a 90 pints of
oil per day person so this used to be a
pint of oil imagine that is full 90
points a day basically means that I am
using one of these every 15 minutes to
support my life all right and so the
average American is using one of these
every 20 something minutes to support
their life so I think when you reduce it
to these terms you you remove the
invisibility of you know we don't
typically see how energy is produced or
used but if you imagine it this way you
really get a visceral feeling for just
how quickly your addiction is I think
the joke here is this is jammed and my
arteries are finally clogged with oil
anyway so let's do it good
ping has a question whose ping we're
sting waiting back there
how would high altitude wind this is a
chance for your plug enhanced geothermal
and nuclear measure up in your watts per
square meter and where does it fit in
renewest and high altitude wind will be
a little higher power density than
traditional wind maybe as higher solar
so I think you want to use that when I
made this presentation
I wanted to say we have to start today
so I'm only using technologies that are
ready to go
hopefully that's ready to go next year
in which case you can add that to the
list and I think we need to use every
resource possible enhance geothermal
it's hard to know how you measure
enhanced geothermal in terms of land use
because it's under land so maybe this is
the the a great argument in favor of
enhanced geothermal I think there's a
great argument in favor of all of them
full-tilt let's go but I'm not I
actually if anyone in the audience who
thinks more deeply about geothermal than
I do haha
then then tell me how we convert that
into a watts per square meter of land
and for nuclear again I don't I'm not
sure how you measure it in in in power
density I will use that as a segue and a
distraction to tell you that I tried to
buy a gas station in Los Angeles you
would ask me why I think it was the CEO
of Chevron used to give this example of
the how glorious fossil fuels were and
if you measure the power density of
gasoline as it's coming out of the
nozzle of the thing that goes into your
car it's astounding it beats all
renewables by a factor of a thousand or
ten thousand or something if you try and
buy a gas station in Los Angeles when
they're trying to sell it to you they
tell you how many gallons of gas it
pumps per month if you take that amount
of energy and you're divided by the land
area required for the gas station not
the nozzle it's about the same as solar
power so how you do the numbers and
statistics can obviously change the way
you think about it so not working for
Chevron let's be a little more fair with
what that what the reference area is
here's a question from Paul Hawken will
pursue this Paul who are you
gradients are there any promethium
technologies that you favor or are
interested in do you think they will be
deployed this again is looking at
technologies coming at us
I okay that is the question actually is
there a get out of jail free technology
get out of jail less expensively than
what you've said so far I
okay I really have racked my brains on
this one
I am I think if you assume that physics
is as we know it the answer is somewhat
no and certainly you don't have 25 years
to develop it so that's also an argument
for a no I think they get out of jail
free card for Humanity is fusion we have
consistently reduced the investment in
fusion
that's the put atoms together not split
them apart form of nuclear power
we've been reducing funding for fusion
for year-over-year for the last few
decades that's just not viable actually
Jim McBride in who's in the audience who
helped me with a lot of the math and all
the slides he has a friend who was a
solar physicist who studies fusion for
the Sun he says oh well if you just give
me two billion dollars I can do my
research project on solar flares and
give you fusion for free so fusion the
fit the consensus among physicists is
not impossible it won't be easy and it
will take some time but we should be
doing that I think that's the closest we
have to a Promethean technology I find
it very hard to imagine we're not going
to double the solar power density when
you know existing photovoltaics get to
40% I think the thermodynamic limit for
photocells will might be 79% or
something the best wind turbines today
operate about 51% extraction efficiency
the theoretical upper limit is fifty
nine point six we're kind of pretty
close we're actually doing pretty well
on those things so there's not a lot of
super way up there stuff I think the
question might be are any of them going
to be really really cheaper and we're
all working on that it's pretty hard to
beat Cole's business model which is you
drive a truck up the hill scrape into
the truck and burn it so that's what
we're shooting for okay here's a
question from it looks like Adrienne
cover Kevin greetings what about carbon
sequestration carbon offsets biochar all
these things that might draw carbon from
the atmosphere just go directly at the
problem a year ago I would have said
let's not even talk about it because I
don't find any of them terribly
palatable I don't biochar they're not
the the results are still out the
reality is for all
these things the results are out carbon
offsets the result is in offsetting does
nothing if you if you want my opinion on
the matter go to cheat offset calm does
anyone know this cheat cheat neutral
calm yeah so it's basically a
conversation but anyway go to cheat
neutral calm you'll get my opinion on on
carbon offsets but on on biochar the
numbers aren't in yet it's not proven
that we can do to scale carbon
sequestration I think we should run
those experiments as soon as possible
it'll cost about six billion dollars to
put them on half a dozen coal plants and
really see if it works we should have
done that yesterday that looks like a
better spend the money than seven
hundred billion dollars on a few banks
so you know we have to what we don't
know about these technologies and their
capacity we should find out next week
James Lovelock refers to carbon offsets
as indulgences yes max marmar how come
so many people are investing in
renewable sources of energy that will
have little impact on humanity's energy
portfolio do you know something they
don't or they just stubborn
which ones some hey max I know max do
you mean wave and title type things I
don't know I think proportionately there
isn't that much money going into those
things deep ocean waves are there sixty
terawatts in deep ocean so if you go
after deep ocean waves maybe it is a
better idea
it's do this then a challenge of
transporting all of that and the
transmission lines so I I'm not sure
that proportionally the investment isn't
terribly well matched to roughly how the
the the portfolio you'd want to invest
in is except maybe for biofuels which I
think has wildly disproportionate
investment compared to its capacity to
solve the problem yeah Kevin Kelly's
right here says and what's say in 50
years you were wrong I hope I am you'll
still be around that one
you missed something and things are not
so bad this is the upscale wrong there's
a downscale wrong would be worth talking
about to you what part of your
calculations are you least confident
about to play to what I know you would
like to talk about I'm also interested
in are there any negative feedbacks in
the climate models that we don't know
about that may be going to help us out
and what I mean by a negative feedback
is do the oceans do something nonlinear
at 410 parts per million that start
sucking more carbon out of the
atmosphere do we so could something like
that happen I think that's the biggest
hope that these numbers are grossly
grossly wrong on the energy production
side it's a little hard to see any glare
I haven't talked to a lot of very smart
people and on every energy we haven't
really found a horrifying like order of
magnitude error anywhere so fingers
crossed there is a negative feedback but
we've been looking now for 10 years and
no one's found a great one yeah are you
tracking on geoengineering schemes and
any of them appeal to you
none of them appeal to me because I just
think we should solve this problem the
right way there so geoengineering the
concept for geoengineering is that you
know well we're already doing
geoengineering we are engineering our
climate but now it's a laissez-faire
kind of engineering we're just you know
warming it up with carbon the concept of
geoengineering can we do very
large-scale climate modification so
examples of that are pouring iron into
the ocean and hoping that you knew you
know you encourage a lot of biotic life
that will then sink to the ocean floor
and sink that carbon another version is
to create clouds over the over the
Arctic and you generate those as a mist
another version is you this is the more
entertaining one that I have
is this this is this fun I don't even
like talking about these things because
you kind of don't want people to know
that this may be an option so you really
aren't I really lost my Republican young
Republican badge the if you'd burnt re
if you had really dirty jet fuel and you
burnt it as you flew around you'd have
more reflective contrails and that would
lower the solar insolation so it's not
inconceivable why I'm not a heart I'm
not a great fan at least that one is
testable so you know I think there there
is a reason for there was a pretty good
conversation about geoengineering now
the guy who I talk to about it most who
I have a lot of respect for the way he
at least frames the problem is Dan
Schrag at Harvard you should all read
what he does and his argument is yes we
should know every single we should do
the research to know every with how
every single one of these works and
here's the the other bit of information
that's interesting the way he thinks
about it is we should be pursuing those
ones that have an off switch that can be
turned off pretty quickly so the take a
nuclear weapon blow up a volcano put
salt from the atmosphere one doesn't
have an off switch that's real good
right the I'll run a few jets with the
jet fuel you can you can test that yeah
by the way there's very little testing
and any of those geoengineering scheme
is going on so far they're referred to
you by the guys who do it is sort of a
hobby they're not getting funding
they're not getting encouragement it's
partly it's because oh my gosh what if
they work then we don't have to all
change our lifestyle to be like yours
and we're barest about that I don't know
not it's actually I think outrageous
that it's still just an intellectual
exercise and all of the geoengineering
schemes that I know of I think as we all
are getting more and more aware of these
days the world is about resource
competition and and in terms of funding
the voices in favor of clean energy
generation are very very loud compared
to this and it's not an insane decision
that I think that the money is being
invested in generation technologies
rather than these
I'll be things baby I would not want the
hobbies to tax the generation research
side but what I would like is more money
to come in to sponsor the hobbies and
make them real discipline hey here's a
money question we're about to get a new
administration next week
Robbins Sloan asks the US government is
about to embark on a spending and
investment project so mind-boggling and
scale that almost fits with the
mind-boggling numbers you've laid out
what would you Saul Griffith secretary
of mind-boggling numbers spend it on I
really want that out of this money
business card I've been looking at new
one that's absolutely fabulous
whoever you come and find me and I'll
thank you so you can put enough abound
on the price which is the good news so
today you can buy a a watt of installed
wind turbine for two bucks and roughly
four bucks will buy your white of
installed solar maybe it's two so okay
we got to do 11 half terawatts that's
roughly 25 terre dollars what's a terre
dollar that i have to go back on so
that's only 25 trillion dollars so okay
that's not a big number
sorry if I'm secretary of mind-boggling
numbers I can say that's a small number
I mean we've we spent a couple of
trillion on Iraq and Afghanistan so far
we've spent I think if you do the larger
numbers but it's not real money in the
market saving but there's been five or
six trillion in total used in this
bailout but that's not quite the same as
a couple of trillion in Iraq because
it's a little more smoke and mirrors so
25 trillion dollars that sounds pretty
cheap for what you see on screen here
25 trillion
yeah I think if we like what is the
surface area of Jim you know it's
probably only a few cents per square
meter of land right so look down and say
I will donate a few pennies or something
actually it's not as probably a couple
of dollars but yeah let's do that so
we're always trying to put dollar
numbers on ecosystem services what's the
value of the stable climate infinite I
mean this is let's let's get this out of
a dollar argument into it and you know
we are deciding the aesthetics and the
quality of life for everyone right down
to our personal quality of lives to the
quality of the global environment you
need to you know dollars are a tool for
putting money and resources around in
the right way but it's not quite the
right unit of measurement it's not an SI
unit last time I checked so it may not
be the right unit to measure the value
of having a let's not even call it a
perfect world anymore let's just shoot
for reasonable yeah
question from Drew endy who's we're
drill over here is this revenge drew
drew drew is on this stage a couple of
weeks ago improve tools make big
problems much easier but people tend to
want solutions now how should we balance
basic research foundational research
with scaling up and implementing what we
already know about do you want me to
give you like what portion is on stuff
that's ready to go today versus stuff
that's ready to go in six years ninety
ten I think we need to we know that sort
of gave you we know how good the solar
cells that we have today are and how
close they are to the best ones you'll
ever get we should be taking the best we
have today and going massively with them
we know how good modern wind turbines
are you need to go massively with those
in the in the in the layout at the same
time you should absolutely be investing
research dollars into resources that we
haven't really
fully used before such as waves beard
near shore or deep ocean high altitude
wind better versions of tidal power
biofuels that go closer to the nine
percent theory and percent theoretical
limit for photo efficiency instead of
the about half a percent that we have
today so you could get a factor of
twenty in biofuels if synthetic biology
bears fruit so money should be going
into the things that we don't know that
the major proportion should also be
going into laying out there the
efficient ones that we do now yeah
what's your sense of the lag time now
between under circumstances are crisis
like World War two like between
basically discovering a plausible likely
potentially scaleable relatively new
technology from discovery to deployment
and most technologies is thirty to forty
years is that gonna be the case AWS I
think high altitude wind enhanced
geothermal wave and titled we don't do
yet all of those are realizable in in
five years and you're starting to really
scale it at five years fusion and really
really efficient biofuels I think might
have longer timelines but true probably
would contend that biofuels may be able
to be brought up faster I'm not sure in
reality I don't hold out a lot of hope
for a magic biofuel that's why I only
apportioned half a terawatt to it and I
also think the power density of biofuels
are sort of problematic but you know
maybe if we could get a factor of 10 in
biofuels that would be that might shift
the shift of the equation there but
there are a few that I just think are
the the problem is it's a
disappointingly small list actually it's
the real problem with that there aren't
that many that we don't know that aren't
that good yeah when I asked you a while
back sir do you have hope and you said
you had hope in terms of yeah we could
do it
humanity has technology and the chops
and maybe the once they figure out
what's really going on the desire do we
have the political ability to make this
happen
in the world I mean the u.s. can do
whatever it wants it's still a fraction
of the big event I'm going to wear my
optimist hat and say we could have the
political will we absolutely don't today
but today is so markedly different than
two years ago the fact that we ratcheted
from 650 to 350 parts per million and
that is now the lingua franca I mean Al
Gore's we're standing up and not being
mocked when he said the new target is
350 in Poznan a couple of weeks ago like
that's a fantastic she's also saying we
do this don't worry in 10 years and get
a lot of jobs doing it you believe that
I do believe you can do that I am
worried about how you phrase it I think
you can absolutely do it I mean the
numbers here will show you can do it but
let's not call that an energy
independence project as it is being sold
energy independence is about oil that
was sold that's a project about that was
through here wind farms for electricity
grid the electricity grid is coal and
nuclear so if you're putting all those
wind turbines doing that right yeah but
that's not so that doesn't solve energy
independence energy independence is
something that replaces you've got to
stop buying oil so I think it's
politically possible it we're not real
yeah I'm just hoping that the
groundswell changes I think one of the
political problems is that we're selling
this as technology will come in and save
it green jobs programs will come in and
save us hopefully tonight you've
realized that the problem is a little
it's not going to be solved by a magic
Promethean technology we will have to
use energy far more wisely
I suspect the more and more people who
start to change their lifestyles to
reflect this because they personally
want the right end outcome will become
exactly the right types of political
lobbyists to make politics get to where
where it has to be and I think that can
happen surprisingly quickly
so everyone sign up for 2200 what life
and loving you hard what do you think
and the chances of that happening are
I'm gonna say we will do it because I'm
gonna have a child in four months this
is the tear choking thing hopefully he
doesn't look like a cardboard gorilla it
is a boy but I think we don't have any
option but to solve it right so I now am
genetically required to be optimistic so
yes and and so this is this is a
fascinating experiment and it's
incredibly difficult for me so that this
this child is born in this year let's
assume that he'll live 80 or 100 years
so everything that we've just said will
play out is going to play out in this
lifetime
hopefully it'll play out whether Kevin
Kelley is something saves the day but
let's assume that it's got to play out
in his lifetime so this kid has to live
it and breathe it and so you know I now
know how to calculate how much energy it
takes to run a life so the kid's gonna
be an experiment actually before day one
I'm already counting every Joule of
energy and every gram of carbon on his
budget funny things horrify me it is you
cannot legally bring a child home from
the hospital without it you you have to
check the baby out of the hospital in a
in a car seat car seat and we don't own
a car seat so I have to buy car seat and
it has to go into a car that has more
than two seats I only have a dune buggy
and the two-seat truck and a two seat
Honda so in order to get my heart my
child home from the hospital this is
this is maybe the best argument we have
for home but I have to buy a new car
and that car cuz I promised myself I'm
never gonna buy a car that car goes on
his budget so they yeah
they won the poor kid is is is chlorine
his way back yeah what was the question
whatever it was yes and I'm gonna stop
showing child porn that's really bad
yeah let's
you're gonna you've given this talk a
few times you're going to give it a few
times more suppose you're giving it in
India and that goes so well or badly or
whatever they're the China says we want
it and bulk well the but your talk
you're gonna they're gonna take you
there in a sailboat or something don't
worry and but to an Indian audience to
an audience of a nation which is busily
getting the hell out of poverty or the
Chinese audience was busily getting the
hell out of poverty everybody's moving
to town they're moving up there they're
making the stuff that we have to buy in
order for that to happen this sounds a
lot to them like some Americans saying
don't do it what we did stay poor I'm I
agree
it sounds imperialist to the nth degree
and coming from a colony that doesn't
like its imperialist overlords I'm not a
huge fan of imperialism colonialism I
don't like the French either did I
mention that they they neutral at all
just outside our so but the serious side
of that question is you say to the in
universe yes this this could sound like
imperialism or this can sound like you
guys are going to be selling your
technologies into America because you
actually know how to live low-power
lifestyles and to change you don't have
the inertia and the infrastructure
challenge that America has I mean
America has the hardest challenge in
solving this problem because in the last
50 years you had free energy and you
build suburbs that are a long way apart
and you built a culture around
profligate energy user there's a lot of
inertia culturally and just in terms of
physical infrastructure that makes it
very hard to solve here
India and China has a much better chance
because they can build that new
infrastructure much more wisely and not
make a lot of the same mistakes so the
optimistic version of the talk to those
audience is you have a great advantage
you also have a lot of cultural skills
and a lot of cultural practices that are
low energy you can export those as
technology as social or otherwise so you
can you you could pitch this as you guys
are really are going to be the new
empire and gonna make a lot of money
doing it because you're you're gonna
teach the rest of the world how to
Solvang there's obviously a whole lot of
ways that that talk wouldn't play out
well but as you know I'm genetically
inclined to be an optimist now so yeah
did I dodged that one enough well it's
interesting I mean it sounds like you've
got a two-prong thing for the for the
developing world stick with a lot of the
traditional practices you have honor
them don't leave them behind because
they are a low impact at the same time
you did amazingly in leapfrogging to
cell phones new technologies that are
relatively efficiency producing light
and low and all the rest of it yeah and
they could lead the world in showing
what are the right technologies to
leapfrog to that do have these lower
impacts oh yeah okay I'm gonna try
another answer all right so you another
way to sell this appropriately and
another reason to think about American
lifestyles more carefully so imagine you
lower the speed limit to 30 miles per
hour right people will drive okay so
what are the for lead we're four of the
top five leading causes of death in the
u.s. are heart disease car accidents
obesity diabetes all of those get
drastically reduced if you subscribe to
a public transit cycling 6/7 vegetarian
lifestyle so you can pitch it to the
developing world you can go down this
path that leads in obesity and high
health care costs and etc etc that will
be a normal social enormous social cost
and etc etc or you can do this the right
way so again I think there's there's
positive spins on all of on all of these
things
and we have to I think absolutely we
have to find positive ways to tell this
entire story it's very easy to look at
all these numbers and be like oh it's
too hard that is there's the impulse but
I think it is just as easy in fact to
say we can actually do it it is an
outside of the capacity humans have done
similar things before in terms of effort
we did it for the wrong reasons like
World War Two and other industrial
efforts but we can we can do it all and
we can if we choose to allow this to
improve our lives right so instead of
spending money on disposable plastic
crap you you still want an economy when
you do this so it's not about just not
buying things it's about using that
money in ways that are much more
rewarding so that there should be a lot
more theater all right you guys all
while some of you donated money tonight
the rest of you should go out and donate
a lot of money to the on the way out the
door to long now because this is the
best way to spend money you're not using
a lot of carbon sitting here and not
using a lot of energy you're being
entertained so there can be a much more
vibrant community abound around things
that you maintain and repair high
quality craftsmanship around cultural
events that's the low energy way to
spend money again I forgot what the
original question was it's you
struggling to stay optimistic yeah
that's right last question the some
behavior changes with talks like this or
slideshows like Al Gore's and movies
like Al Gore's mostly pave behavior
changes with events in the world and one
can imagine a good news event a sense
that wow something or the work that is
reversing the thing maybe will feel good
about financial decline for a while more
typically behavior changes around a bad
event or or more effectively a sequence
of two or preferably three bad events
which are interpreted the same way so
when we had 35,000 people die in 2003 in
the summer and Europe from what
everybody thought was an unusual
heatwave
it went by nobody as far as I know
thought that was something serious
Katrina maybe but you know it's a maybe
thing we always had hurricanes will
always have hurricanes was a climate
wasn't it do you have a sense of what
good news or bad news would change
behavior on the good I'm not sure what
good news event changes behavior I mean
in this topic except everyone's nearing
a scheme that works to get a sense of it
and we might be able to get a handle on
part of it that kind of thing
right okay that I think those things
will will help a lot those there's good
those those events that say these
technologies these strategies are
working and positive feedback around
those things will be probably laser
fusion you know across the bay they're
doing laser fusion supposed to be better
than magnetic fusion it shows promise
right where is that in the headline yeah
you know actually I wrote an article for
make magazine last year on this you know
the the most incredible headline of the
decade if not the last quarter century
happened last year we turned on the
Large Hadron Collider right 60,000
engineers from every country in the
world built the largest machine that
humans have ever built it's this is like
this is the pyramids of our tires but
it's all stainless steel steel and it
looks like a Swiss watch buried you know
18 yeah eight miles in diameter under
under Geneva absolutely incredible it
turned on and it worked for a little
while right and that's amazing that we
can take our tiny little monkey brains
and we can get all those people to work
together and we can design the most
incredible fantastic thing and what is
it to do it's to ask the most
fundamental questions that are or what
what is mass right we all think we know
what weight and mass are but we kind of
don't at a fundamental level so we built
the most expensive machine complex
machine ever with all these people to
answer that fundamental question and in
and it it worked first time it's it's
now not operational but it will be
bought back online that has to that was
the best news story for four decades
completely sort of missed by the popular
media so we need to get those stories
and
some of them around in-house geothermal
and high altitude wind power and the new
new solar thermal technologies and more
you know things like the apt error which
is a electric car that that is designed
the right way they should be great you
see more about that one that another one
apt error is really a motorcycle
disguised as a car that so the secret
for cars to be efficient you don't want
to see this alright sir sorry I really
almost made it all the way without
equations travel in a vacuum that's a
good ship so this is this is so actually
these two slides are here these are the
only two slides these are the only two
equations you need to know if you care
about energy use right so all nearly all
of humanity's energy use goes through
one of these or the other in an
engineering sense so this is sort of the
engineers version of the fluid drag
equation so the amount of power it takes
to push something through a fluid is
proportional half of the density of the
fluid that's running through times the
drag coefficient that's the purple one
times the reference area that's the blue
a times the velocity V cubed right so
you want to lower you want to increment
that cube is the killer the cube is the
killer so the very first thing you do is
take the cube and you make things go
slow this is why you go to 30 mile per
hour speed limits and increase the speed
that you get across the city but you
also make things fish shape the apt
errors fish-shaped you make the
reference area small its reference area
small it doesn't travel in a vacuum
unfortunately but that one's kind of
hard to work and you know it's not very
atmosphere actually I'll be the norm so
you know I think there's a lot of good
news stories out there and we really
should celebrate them into the second
half of your question
all right so bad news stories I try to
be an optimist so there's going to be
there could be some I you know I've
played out all sorts of dark scenarios
when you look at all these numbers you
go through every possible emotion you
you're you're elated you're depressed
you're all those things so I've had
plenty of time to think about bad
scenarios so all of the water that feeds
into Pakistan comes through the Indus
that runs through India all of that
water in turn
is glacial melt from the Himalayas so
global warming heat up less place you'll
melt flowing into India India takes its
share there's nothing left for Pakistan
Pakistan is nuclear-armed in your is
nuclear-armed China siding with Pakistan
America's siding with India we can all
get pretty creative about how this one
ends that will look like you're the
clash of civilizations or whatever
people want to call it that's a climate
change problem so you know there's
scenarios like that there's but
interesting because we've got a resource
war in Darfur we don't think of it in
those terms
sort of one in the Mideast between
Palestine and Israel but that would
really be a resource where it's really
clear that the water coming off the
Himalayan plateau is being turned off by
the guys upstream yeah so that one
doesn't look good
bird flu outbreak in in Asia after the
couple of horrifying tsunamis hit in
Southeast Asia that that also could be a
sort of a climate problem that we're
gonna call something else so I think
there's a you can I'm not there's no
need to tease it out there's enough
we've all read all the Horace Story
scenarios they're all somewhat possible
hopefully they're not terribly possible
I don't think we should dwell on them a
lot we should just get to work and do
what we know we have to do and and and
actually build the most beautiful world
you can that sort of fits these
constraints I used to say in this
instead of some version of this talk you
know how did we end up here so I think
the the problem was you know we figured
out that the world the world was round
right while ever the world was flat
spiracle yes correct
but while over the world and them was
flat you could conceive that was
infinite there's gonna be everything of
everything right the first moment we
knew that the world was circle should
mean our okay so it's a finite system
maybe we should think about how we
manage the resources and and be careful
it took us about two or three hundred
years after we realized that - that's
the leg yeah so that lag time is a
little we don't have that much luxury
now but I think this is really you know
the Club of Rome was
was famous a long time ago for sort of
doing the first attempt at what are the
resource limits I think we're actually
facing them much more realistically now
I don't think it's horrifying we just
have to learn to work within more
reasonable resource limits the bottom
line is you have to work thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you